monsieur le président de l'ukraine vous
avez la parole
merci c'est un grand honneur pour moi
pour le cren et pour notre peuple
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
mesdames et messieurs les parlementaires
les élus de paris le peuple français
je suis reconnaissant d'avoir l'honneur
de m'adresser à vous aujourd'hui
je suis sûr que vous savez très bien ce
qui se passe en ukraine vous savez
pourquoi cela se produit et vous savez
qui est coupable
et même ceux qui se garent qui cache la
tête dans le sable
et c'est de trouver de l'argent en
russie
et je m'adresse à vous aux gens honnêtes
rationnelle et audacieux
et je voudrais poser une question
comment arrêter cette guerre comment
instaurer la paix en ukraine parce que
la plupart des questions et des réponses
sont dans vos mains dans nos mains le 9e
marché
les bombes aériennes russes ont été
lancés sur l'hôpital pour les enfants et
une maternité dans notre vie de mario
paul c'était une vie
paisible dans le sud de l'ukraine
complètement paisible jusqu'à ce que les
troupes russes sont venus et l'ont pris
dans un siège brutal comme au moyen âge
ils ont commencé à tuer les les gens
dans cette maternité
sur laquelle le russe ont lancé les bobs
il y avait des gens il y avait des
femmes qui se préparait à accoucher et
la plupart d'entre eux
ont survécu mais certaines ont été
gravement blessées et une femme a dû
amputer son pied qui était fracturée et
une autre femme avait en bassin fracturé
et son bébé est mort avant la naissance
la femme on a on essayait de sauver la
femme
elles demandaient les médecins de
laisser mourir de ne pas l'aider
elle ne vais pas dire ne voyez pas de
raisons pour vivre
elle est morte en ukraine en europe en
quand des centaines de millions de
personnes ne peuvent pas penser que que
le monde pouvait être détruits
et je vous demande d'observer une minute
de silence à l'honneur à la mémoire des
milliers de livres aignan et d'ukraine
yen qui ont été tuées à la suite de
l'invasion russe du territoire au kenya
merci
après les semaines l'opposition russe
marie paule et d'autres villes
ukrainiennes frappé par l'occupant
rappelle les ruines de verdun
comme sur les photos de la première
guerre mondiale
que chacun et chacune
à vue a vu l'armée russe ne distingue
pas les objets qu'il cible ils
détruisent tous les quartiers
résidentiels les hôpitaux les écoles les
universités de dos ils brûlent les
entrepôts de nourriture et de
médicaments
et brutaux
ne prend pas en compte les concepts de
crimes de guerre
les causes obligations sur les
conventions et ils ont apporté la
terreur sur la seule ligne à et chacun
de vous un inconscient vous avez toutes
les informations tout est disponible
tous les faits sur les femmes violées
par les militaires russes dans les zones
est temporairement occupés sur les
réfugiés
qui culture sur les routes sur les
journalistes keltoum sachant exactement
que ce sont des journalistes
sur les anciens qui ont survécu à
l'holocauste et sont maintenant obligés
de fuir dans les abris anti bandes des
frappes russe
l'europe
n'a pas vu depuis 80
dans l'europe n'a pas vu ce qui s'est
passé en ukraine
il y a des gens désespérés qu'il supplie
de mourir
en 2010 neuf ans je suis devenu
président il y avait déjà en format pour
les négociations avec la fédération de
la russie c'était un format normandie le
format d'une récession qui devrait
mettre fin à la guerre dans les zones
basses la guerre à l'est de l'ukraine
qui dure depuis huit ans malheureusement
et 4 dames ont participé au format
normandie l'ukraine la russie
l'allemagne et la france
4 mais il représentait tout le monde le
monde entier les positions du monde
entier toutes les positions quelqu'un le
soutenions et quelqu'un a essayé de
retarder le processus et ils voulaient
le perturber mais il semblait important
que le monde soit toujours à cette table
normandie
et donc il y avait des résultats des
négociations quand nous avons réussi à
libérer les gens de la captivité quand
nous avons pu négocier certaines
décisions en 2019 c'était une bouffée
d'air frais comme une leur d'espoir
l'espoir que les conversations avec la
russie peuvent aider que les dirigeants
de la russie peuvent être persuadé par
les paroles que moscou peut choisir la
paix mais le 24 février evegnon le jour
qui a barré tous les efforts
et même le concept du mot dialogue
et la barre et l'expérience européenne
des relations avec la russie elle est
destinée de l'histoire en europe tout
cela a été bombardée par les troupes
russes écrasé par l'artillerie russe et
brûlé après les tirs de missiles russes
on n'a pas trouvé de vérité dans les
bureaux
et on est obligé de chercher la vérité
sur le champ de bataille
alors qu'est ce qui nous reste nos
valeurs l'unité et la détermination de
défendre notre liberté
notre liberté commune pour paris et pour
kiev pour berlin et varsovie pour madrid
et rome pour russell et bratislav
les bouffées d'air frais ne nous
aideront pas
nous devons agir ensemble
faire la pression ensemble pour faire la
russie a cherché la peine mesdames et
messieurs le peuple français le 24
février
le peuple ukrainien ce qui est
aujourd'hui nous n'avons plus ni de
représentant 3 n'y des représentants de
gauche nous ne faisons pas attention à
ce qui est ce qui représentait le
pouvoir
et la coalition et l'opposition et on
pense de l'instauration de la paix
pour protéger notre pays nous sommes
reconnaissants à la france
que la france nous aide nous sommes très
reconnaissants pour les efforts du
président macron qui a fait preuve d'un
véritable leadership nous ni constamment
avec lui nous coordonnons nos pas et les
ukrainiens on voit que la france
apprécie également la vérité et vous les
protégez
vous vous savez ce que c'est la liberté
l'égalité la fraternité
et chaque parole est important pour vous
je le sens et les ukrainiens le récente
et nous attendons de la france de votre
leadership
que vous puissiez faire en sorte que la
russie cherche la peine pour mettre fin
à cette guerre contre la liberté contre
l égalité contre la fraternité contre
tout skieur rendu l'europe unie et
libre et diverses nous attendons de la
france de votre leadership la
restauration de l'intégrité territoriale
de l'ukraine on peut le faire ensemble
et s'il ya ceux qui ont des doutes entre
les personnes présentes alors je peux
vous dire que votre peuple est sûr comme
tous les autres peuples de l'europe
et pendant la présidence française de
l'union européenne
une décision
mûrie sur apprises sur l'adhésion de
l'ukraine à l'union européenne une
décision historique à un moment
historique
comme cela a toujours été le cas dans
l'histoire du peuple français
mesdames et messieurs le peuple français
demain ce sera au mois que les
ukrainiens se battent pour leur liés de
leur liberté que notre armée se pose de
manière isolée et or et ori oric aux
forces supérieures de la russie
nous avons besoin d'eux dad encore plus
dette de plus de soutien pour que la
liberté ne perdent pas elle doit être
bien armé les chars les armes anti-char
les l'avion de combat des français rien
vous pouvez nous aider nous en avons
besoin vous pouvez pour que la liberté
ne tarde pas le monde doit les soutenir
avec des sanctions contre l'agresseur
chaque semaine on ne voit pas cas de
sanction les entreprises françaises
doivent quitter les le marché russe
renom au chant leroy merlin et autres
doivent cesser d'être les sponsors de la
machine de guerre de la russie
les
doivent arrêter de financer le meurtre
d'enfants et de femmes le viol
tout le monde va se rappeler que les
valeurs
valent plus que des bénéfices
et nous devons déjà pensé de l'avenir de
la façon dont nous allons vivre après la
guerre il faut des garanties y ait des
garanties sur
que la sécurité sera inébranlable et que
les gars ne seront plus possibles dans
ce monde
nous créons ce système de garantie aux
nouveaux systèmes de sécurité
ou la france aura un rôle de premier
plan pour que personne
ne devrait jamais en pleurer la mort
pour que les gens vivent leur lit
et pour qu'on dise à dio pas sous les
bombes pas en état de guerre
mais quand leurs liens
avec la dignité parce que nous devons
vivre pour être respectées
pour qu'on déguise de revoir
comme les français a dit au revoir à
belmondo
merci apprend ce couloir a le crâne
[Applaudissements]